hey everyone I'm Sharla on his own and
today I wanted to talk about what makes
Pokemon so important now of course if
you're around my age you will have grown
up around the cards and the TV show and
it came white everything was all new and
exciting and we all pretty much loved it
anyway but of course that's all why I
find Pokemon so important or so
appealing it's because the games
themselves are actually pretty
phenomenal
so to start with there are 655 Pokemon
at this point you have to choose six of
those then of course these pokemon have
types a lot of Pokemon have two types so
there are around 150 individual
combinations then you get to pick four
specific moves out of 95 teams they were
in black too to have your Pokemon have
of course they will evolve and have
certain ones and somewhat dapat a ball
but basically you get to choose all
moves out of a giant library out of an
even bigger library either one even
bigger library of Pokemon on top of that
there is Eevee trading so I'm not going
to go into Eevee training because it is
a little bit complicated but basically
depending on the pokémon that you fight
in the wild you will get certain stat
points this means if you're paying
attention to Eevee training you can
specify what stat boosts your Pokemon
will have individually so the one they
get to level 100 they will be completely
different to someone else's at level 100
so really it's about picking the
specific Pokemon down to it t-too
exactly what you need them to do and it
is incredibly complicated and incredibly
customizable and it's so much deeper
than it appears to be on the surface so
what I think makes Pokemon different to
a lot of other RPGs is that they will
throw combat at you as a way to sort of
stop you from progressing whereas the
appeal of Pokemon is the progression of
your team and customizing them even
further and bringing up this group of
six things you've individually selected
all by yourself I mean it's outstanding
so I think what makes me so passionate
about Pokemon or why I feel like Pokemon
is really important is that it's really
about the gameplay and that's all we're
games started
you know we started with space invaders
we started with Tetris you know stuff
that was all about the games not about
the stories and it carries itself to
have thousands of people finishing these
games just on that alone it doesn't need
flashy cutscenes and it doesn't need a
story now I'm saying that I do love
story waste games as well but there are
an abundance of them and I think that
most games as they progress sort of get
more stories and more cutscenes and more
characters and they really develop on
that so think about how impressive it is
that Pokemon instead has added more
Pokemon and made your decisions more
complex it's all about you it's not
about what it tells you to think I also
definitely don't think Pokemon is
necessarily better than games that a
story driven because a lot of my
favorite games are really story focused
but I do think it deserves the credit
even if people don't enjoy playing it or
they hate the grinding which can come
around and can get annoying so thank you
everyone for watching those are just my
thoughts on a white Pokemon is so tops
let me know in the comments below what
you think about Pokemon what your
favorite Pokemon game is who's your
favorite Pokemon because I'm always down
to chat a little bit of Pokemon